sony has issued an encouraging but
indecisive response to microsoft's
invitation to unite the online networks
of PlayStation 4 and Xbox one with
inserting games on Monday Microsoft
publicly invited other platform holders
to allow the same games to be played
online across different console networks
such an unprecedented move if enacted
could bring an end to more than a decade
of segregation between the PlayStation
Network and Xbox Live Sony's response
issued one day later suggests that the
market leading platform holder remains
open-minded about cross console play but
stopped short of discussing a deal with
Xbox Live PlayStation has been
supporting cross-platform play between
PC on several software titles starting
with Final Fantasy 11 on ps2 and PC back
in 2002 we would be happy to have the
conversation with any publishers or
developers who are interested in
cross-platform play on Monday Microsoft
made the eye catching announcement that
it will support cross-platform play
between the Xbox one Windows 10 and
other online multiplayer networks the
movie fective Lee opens the Xbox Live
platform so that it can accommodate
players on other game networks the first
Xbox one game announced to take
advantage of this cross-platform
connectivity will be rocket League which
will soon allow Xbox one and PC
customers to play against each other
online such a feature is already present
in the ps4 version which has always
allow PSM players to set of matches with
players on Steam but Microsoft has
indicated that now wants to bridge the
gap between its console and Sony's and
went as far as saying that groundwork
had been complete on Monday its indie
developer director Chris charla said in
addition to natively supporting
cross-platform play between Xbox one and
Windows 10 games that use Xbox Live
we're enabling developers to sport cross
network play as well this means players
on Xbox one on Windows 10 using Xbox
Live will be able to play with players
on different online multiplayer networks
including other consoles and PC networks
so what are your thoughts about a
unified online gaming network let us
know in the comments section below or
find me on Twitter at a regular Dave and
for all your gaming news stay tuned to
games.com